nous vivons une période exceptionnelle
de pandémie covit 19 une maladie virale
extrêmement contagieuse qui a déjà fait
des dizaines de milliers de morts
à l'heure actuelle il semble qu'il
faille encore envisager le risque que
qu'ovide 19 face des millions de nord
d'ici la fin de l'année
dans ce contexte il semble urgent
d'accélérer les recherches cliniques
pour trouver les traitements efficaces
contre qu'ovide 19 sauf que pour
vraiment tester ces traitements il va
falloir les administré à des patients
atteints de colite 10,9 alors même qu'on
sera encore dans l'incertitude sur
l'efficacité de ces traitements
il ya en fait même un vrai risque que le
traitement en question soit en fait
néfaste et que la recherche de
traitements efficaces qu en fait des
dégradations des conditions des patients
en fait pour chaque patients
actuellement atteints de colite 19 ans
plus de l'horrible dilemme éthique
d'accepter vous refusez sa prise en
charge faute de ressources humaines et
matérielles
il y à un dilemme éthique additionnel
auquel on est confronté à savoir faut-il
faire de notre mieux pour le bien de
chaque patient en l'état de nos
connaissances ou faut-il prendre le
risque d' expérimenter des nouveaux
traitements dont l'efficacité est encore
très incertaine dans l'espoir que si ces
traitements fonctionnent on puisse ainsi
le découvrir et l'utiliser pour sauver
une fraction importante des patients
futur faut-il prendre le risque de
mettre en danger était centaines ou des
milliers de patients actuels ou du moins
de ne pas leur administrer le meilleur
traitement connu à ce jour pour le bien
de millions de patients futur ce dilemme
éthique c'est un dilemme bien connue des
informaticiens des mathématiciens
on l'appelle le dilemme exploration et
exploitation intuitivement quand on est
encore très ignorants il est important
de tenter des choses et de prendre des
risques
pour en apprendre davantage puis une
fois qu'on en sait davantage
on peut exploiter nos connaissances par
exemple pour sauver des vies alors dit
comme ça ça peut paraître simple mais la
mise en pratique de ce principe simple
est un sacré des filles
comment peut-on savoir si à un moment
donné il faut davantage explorer et
tenter de nouveaux traitements quitte à
mettre en danger des vies et ne pas
offrir le meilleur traitement identifié
jusque là
à partir de quand peut-on se dire qu'on
en sait suffisamment pour arrêter
l'expérimentation et se contenter de ce
conseil de mieux
jusque là habituellement pour les
traitements médicaux on procède d'abord
avec une phase d'exploration
celle ci consiste en une série d'essais
cliniques qui sont divisés en phase pré
clinique phase 1 pour vérifier l'absence
d'effets secondaires indésirables phase
ii pour ajuster les doses à prescrire et
estimer l'efficacité du traitement et
phase iii pour affiner cette estimation
et la comparer à l'efficacité de
traitement alternatif et du placebo puis
on a une phase de déploiement ou le
médicament est autorisé à la vente est
prescrit par les médecins
c'est ce qu'on appelle la phase 4 c'est
la phase d'exploitation des
connaissances acquises pendant les
essais cliniques
notez que cette procédure est aussi la
plus commune en machine learning jusque
là où les algorithmes sont d'abord
conçus peaufiner entraîné et tester
avant d'être ensuite déployée cependant
est ce vraiment là la meilleure façon de
procéder et surtout comment optimiser au
mieux la transition entre exploration et
exploitation
quel calcul pourra être effectuée pour
mieux comprendre le moment optimal pour
effectuer cette transition alors bien
sûr en pratique il y a énormément plus
de considération extrêmement difficile à
prendre en compte comme le bien-être des
patients leur consentement à prendre un
risque pour avancer notre connaissance
et plein d'autres aspects que je ne
maîtrise absolument pas bien conduire
des tests cliniques
c'est compliqué néanmoins en cours des
dernières décennies en s'appuyant
notamment sur vent sur le belize à nice
mme un très grand nombre d'études ont
proposé de nombreuses astuces pour
accélérer les essais cliniques
on parle typiquement de tests contrôle
et adaptatif par opposition aux tests
contrôlé randomisé dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 8
c'est est contrôlé adaptatif ou de bien
meilleures propriétés mathématiques qui
suggèrent qu'il pourrait permettre
d'arriver plus rapidement à des
conclusions plus robuste sur
l'efficacité de différents traitements
avec même déjà de nombreuses mises en
pratique et des résultats encourageants
en tout cas ça semble avoir convaincu la
food and drug administration aux états
unis
la f10 est qui s'est mise à encourager
la recherche et la mise en pratique de
ces tests contrôle et adaptatif
malheureusement ces tests semblent
encore peu appliqués en pratique
mais il ya une bonne raison à cela cette
étude en particulier rapportent des
mises en pratique bancale des tests
contrôler adha
natif ces tests étant un peu plus
complexe il est important de prendre
soin qu'on les applique dans des cas
d'applications adaptées et avec une
rigueur adéquat ce qui va m'intéresser
en particulier aujourd'hui c'est de vous
présenter les motivations des tests
control adaptatif les aspects critiques
de ces approches et l'ordre de grandeur
du nombre de vies qui pourraient ainsi
être sauvées en s'appuyant dessus et
pour cela je vais m'appuyer sur le
modèle le plus simple des tests contrôle
et adaptatif appelé modèle du bandit à
plusieurs bras ou multi arts de bain dit
en anglais le nom vient des casinos mais
nous nous étalons pas sur les détails
parlons du modèle imaginé qu'à chaque
instant un nouveau patient arrive et
vous avez plusieurs traitements à votre
disposition disons que vous pouvez lui
administrer des pilules bleues rouges
vertes magenta ou jaune parmi ces
traitements il y a généralement un
placebo même si techniquement on
pourrait vouloir juste comparer
différentes pilules dont on sait déjà
qu'elles sont toutes plus efficace qu'un
placebo en pratique dans le cas de co
vide 19 l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a lancé un plan d'essais cliniques
de solidarité appelé solidarity triumph
qui consiste à tester quatre traitements
à base de mélange adéquat de rennes dvir
de lopinavir de ritonavir d'interféron
bêta et de chloroquine est à comparer
les performances de ces traitements au
traitement standard actuel
c'est donc finalement un peu comme si on
disposait effectivement de cinq pilules
différentes dont les performances
curative sont encore très méconnu on est
donc là dans un cas pratique qui
ressemble finalement pas mal
ok à théorique que je suis en train de
présenter quoi qu'il en soit la grosse
difficulté c'est que a priori vous ne
connaissez pas les efficacité de ces
différentes pilule autrement dit vous ne
connaissez pas la probabilité qu'un
patients survivent
si vous lui donnez telle ou telle pilule
pour mieux soigner les patients futur il
nous faut mieux estimer les probabilités
de survie
suite aux différents traitements et pour
cela il nous faut faire de l'exploration
alors pour aujourd'hui je vais me
concentrer en particulier sur les essais
cliniques en phase iii et en particulier
ça correspond à faire de l'exploration
en phase iii des essais cliniques
l' approche actuelle la plus standards
des essais cliniques
3 en gros c'est d'administrer
aléatoirement l'une des cinq pilules à
tout nouveau patient pendant une longue
phase d'exploration
et au bout d'un moment on fait le bilan
et on estime les probabilités paix bleus
pérouges pévère paix magenta et paix
jaune en fonction de la fréquence de
survie des patients jusque là
puis on passe en mode exploitation on
administre à tous les passions futur la
pilule avec la meilleure fréquence de
survie empirique jusque là bien sûr ce
que je décris là c'est une
simplification extrême de la manière
dont fonctionne effectivement les essais
cliniques en pratique encore une fois
c'est bien plus compliqué que cela il ya
notamment toute sorte de procédure pour
prendre en charge des patients traités
qui présenteraient des effets
secondaires inquiétants suit un
traitement nouveau et a également un
suivi de toutes sortes de metric autre
que la survie des patients
ceci dit ça reste grosso modo vu de loin
au moins la logique globale qui est
suivi par la plupart des tests cliniques
quoi qu'il en soit maintenant qu'on a
formalisé le problème on peut se
demander si cette stratégie est une
bonne stratégie en particulier est ce
une stratégie qui maximise le nombre de
vies sauvées
imaginons que la meilleure pilule et la
pilule bleue
le problème c'est qu'à cause des
fluctuations statistiques il ya une
probabilité non nul que pendant la phase
d'exploration
la pilule rouge correspondent à une
meilleure fréquence empirique de survie
des patients que la pilule bleue mais
alors pendant tout le reste du temps
n'administre à une pilule sous-optimale
et ça ça peut être en fait
catastrophique
en effet imaginons que la pilule rouge
paraît prometteuse et que tout le monde
se jette dessus
imaginons que les états imposent de son
administration à tout patient malade du
coc vie de 19 et que très vite trop vite
tout le monde se met à croire que la
pilule rouge elle le traitement miracle
mais imaginons qu'en fait la pilule
bleue est légèrement meilleure imaginons
que sur 100 patients en état critique
la pilule bleue sauve une vie de plus en
moyenne que la pilule rouge
le fait d'avoir conclu trop vite à
l'efficacité de la pilule rouge serait
alors catastrophique sur 10 millions de
patients en état critique
cent mille patients vont alors mourir
alors qu'ils auraient été sauvées si la
pilule
le avait été adopté le fait d'avoir
échoué à détecter une très légère
supériorité de la pilule bleue sur la
pilule rouge aurait ainsi causer cent
mille morts additionnel mais alors
comment éviter cela quelle doit être la
taille de l'échantillon testé pour
maximiser le nombre de vies sauvées sur
combien de patients doit-on alors se
permettre d'effectuer des
expérimentations comment déterminer le
moment où l'on peut passer à
l'exploitation bien dans notre modèle
mathématique on peut fournir une réponse
à ces questions
pour maximiser le nombre de vies sauvées
ou plutôt l'espérance du nombre de vies
sauvées car il faut raisonner avec
l'incertitude
le nombre de patients sur lesquels on
effectue les tests doit être de l'ordre
de 2 fois le log de grands à une fois
delta carré diviser par deux le tout
divisé par delta carré ou quand est né
le nombre total de patients à traiter
passé présent et futur et delta est la
différence d'efficacité entre le
meilleur traitement est le second
meilleur traitement
dans l'exemple que j'ai donné on avait
une différence d'environ 1 mort tous les
sens qu'à ce qui correspond à delta à
peu près égale à 0 01
imaginons maintenant que à cause de
covit 19 10 millions de patients seront
un état critique
pour minimiser l'espérance du nombre de
vies sauvées le nombre de tests doit
être de l'ordre de 120 milles dans toute
honnêteté quand j'ai fait les calculs
j'ai été très surpris par ce résultat
qui est bien plus grand que ce à quoi je
m'attendais en particulier de façon
préoccupante
ce nombre est bien supérieur à celui des
essais cliniques en phase iii usuels ou
des milliers de sujets sont
habituellement tester d'où l'urgence à
prendre le temps de bien réfléchir et de
choisir adéquatement la taille des
échantillons des essais cliniques
prendre des échantillons trop petit et
conclure trop tôt c'est indirectement
potentiellement sacrifier des centaines
de milliers de vies bien sûr en pratique
encore une fois n'est pas uniquement
question de sauver des vies le bien-être
des patients peut et doit aussi être
prise en compte dans l'analyse
mais au moins les ordres de grandeur est
similaire
bien mesurer des petites variations de
l'effet d'un changement de traitement et
critique lorsque le traitement est
déployé à très grande échelle mais
mesurée robustement ces petites
variations nécessite des tests sur un
très très grand nombre de patients donc
non il ne s'agit pas de se précipiter de
court circuiter un minimum de rigueur
statistiques et de conclure après avoir
effectué des tests sur 100 patients
seulement
d'autant que en pratique il y à une
multitude d'autres facteurs à prendre en
compte comme les particularités
physiologiques des différents patients
l'évolution de leur pathologie au cours
du temps et l'incertitude sur le nombre
total de cas qu'il pourrait y avoir et
prendre en compte tout cela ça nécessite
encore plus de rigueur et de réflexion
pire encore d'un point de vue
statistique
en pratique il n'ya pas que cela il se
pose aussi la question de la fiabilité
des données en particulier pour que
l'analyse que l'on vient de faire soit
valide il faut que pendant la phase de
traitement
le choix du traitement aux patients
soient choisis de manière randomisée
sont ceux là on est vouée à subir toutes
sortes de facteurs de confusion et de
tomber dans l'horrible piège du paradoxe
de simpson
si vous ne savez pas de quoi je parle
mettez pose est allé voir cette vidéo où
cette vidéo je suis sérieux si vous
voulez être capable de faire des bonnes
analyses de données
il faut absolument que vous connaissiez
ce paradoxe sur le bout des doigts car
sinon vous êtes vous et à faire
énormément d'erreurs dans vos analyses
de données que ces années y soit faite
sur vos ordinateurs ou dans votre
cerveau alors il ya une limite toutefois
au raisonnement convient de faire ou on
a supposé que la différence d'efficacité
entre le meilleur traitement est le
second meilleur traitement et est de
0,01
en pratique on ne connaît pas à ce
nombre ce qui nous empêche de déterminer
la taille adéquate de la population sur
laquelle on effectue les tests pour
résoudre ce problème
les mathématiciens ont trouvé une astuce
adapter la taille de l'échantillon en
fonction de la différence entre les
fréquences empirique
plus précisément l'idée est ici de
poursuivre les tests jusqu'à ce que les
différences entre les fréquences
empirique de survie pour le meilleur et
le second traitement est supérieur
à deux fois la racine carrée de lob de
grands et / p tit n
le tout divisé par petite trentaine
encore une fois est le nombre total de
patients passé présent futur qu'il faut
traiter et petites haines et le nombre
de patients qui ont été traités jusque
là et sur lequel on a fait en
particulier de l'expérimentation
ainsi après petit n est égale à dix
mille expérimentation si on s'attend à
grand peine de l'ordre de 10 millions de
cas à traiter
alors le seuil deux fois racine carrée
de l'ocs deux grands thèmes / br / p tit
n elle lui de l'ordre de 0,05 et donc si
à ce moment là l'écart empirique entre
les deux traitements et de l'ordre de
0,01
alors cette analyse nous encourage à
poursuivre les expérimentations en fait
pour un tel écart empirique il faudra
poursuivre jusqu'à environ 180 milles
expérimentation ce qui est cohérent avec
l'ordre de grandeur de 120000 qu'on a
établi plus tôt mais l avantage c'est
que cette fois on pourra décider
d'arrêter l'expérimentation des
traitements après seulement deux mille
patients
si on se rend compte que à ce moment là
la différence entre le meilleur est le
second meilleur traitement est supérieur
à 0,13
autrement dit si sur 2000 patients
traités de manière randomisée le
meilleur traitement sauf 130 vie de plus
que le second meilleur traitement
alors on pourra stopper l'exploration
est passé à l'exploitation de cette
information
en administrant le meilleur traitement
identifié jusque-là au reste de la
population
voilà qui permettrait ainsi d'accélérer
le déploiement d'un traitement très
largement supérieure à toute autre
traitement connu jusque là et alors oui
si vous êtes habitué au protocole
classique d'essais cliniques et à la
paix valu ce que je viens de dire peut
peut être vous choquer profondément je
suis en train de vous présenter une
façon de tester et de sélectionner des
traitements qui autorise l'arrêt
prématuré des expériences ce qui
invalide l'erreur de type 1 et je n'ai
absolument pas fait appel à la notion de
preuve d'efficacité ou des effets
statistiquement significative bien il se
trouve que comme on en a beaucoup parlé
dans cette série pour bien raisonner ces
notions ne semble pas si fondamental
voir pas si utile en tout cas à en
croire le bail à nice mme ou encore en
croire le consensus des statisticiens
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 13 donc
s'il vous plaît je sais que ce n'est pas
facile mais s'il vous plaît essayez
d'éviter d'utiliser ces expressions très
trompeuse et essayer d'adopter un
langage beaucoup plus probabiliste
après tout la question qui importe
peut-être davantage c'est si en l'état
actuel de nos connaissances et de nos
incertitudes la taille des effets
probables du traitement le plus
prometteur est suffisamment supérieure à
toute autre taille des faits probable de
tout autre traitement potentiel de sorte
que cette différence justifie une
prescription systématique de ce
traitement à des centaines de milliers
de patients voire à la dizaine de
millions de cas critiques à venir en
fait pour sauver davantage de vies
on peut faire bien mieux encore en tout
cas sur le plan théorique au lieu
d'avoir une phase d'exploration pur
suivie d'une phase d'exploitation pur
les mathématiciens ont proposé d'autres
approches où il ya une transition
continue ou l'exploration diminue
progressivement au profit de
l'exploitation
par exemple certains ont proposé un
algorithme appelé ucb pour eux peur
confie dance pas honte
là encore malheureusement je ne vais pas
m'attarder sur la terminologie pourtant
intéressante de cet algorithme à chaque
instant cet algorithme ucb mélange
l'exploration et l'exploitation en
choisissant d'administrer le traitement
qui maximise une quantité égale un terme
d'exploitation + 1 termes d'exploration
le terme d'exploitation correspond à
l'efficacité empirique du traitement sur
les données passées alors que
l'exploration intègre l'incertitude sur
l'efficacité de ce traitement qui est
d'autant plus grande que peu de tests
ont été effectués avec ce traitement x
un terme qui croît très lentement avec
le temps de façon très intéressante
l'algorithme ucb al avantage de ne pas
nécessiter d'estimation au préalable du
nombre de cas grand aisne qu'il faudra
traiter nous encore les mathématiciens
ou même prouvé que des variantes un poil
plus sophistiqué de cet algorithme
notamment qu'à elle ucb développer en
2013 sont en fait en un sens optimale il
existe même des variantes bayésienne
encore plus prometteuse en tout cas à
mon sens notamment à base
d'échantillonnage de thomson
mais je ne vais malheureusement pas
avoir le temps de vous en parler et
croyez moi je suis premier déçu dans le
cas de kevin 19 ce pourrait être des
milliers peut-être même des dizaines de
milliers de vies qui serait ainsi
sauvées si on appliquer qu à l ucb
plutôt que l' approche exploration pu
leur exploitation pur qu'on a présenté
plus tôt mais bien sûr encore une fois
sa mise en oeuvre pratique est bien plus
complexe notamment d'un point de vue
administratif
ceci dit de façon très intéressante les
outils d'urgence qu'a proposé l'om est
notamment dans le cadre du solidari
titre ailleurs le temps de pouvoir
permettre une implémentation au moins
partielle de ces idées qu'à tout ça ce
sera sans doute très intéressant à
analyser
d'un point de vue méthodologique
alors bien sûr en pratique tout est plus
compliqué que ceux dont on vient de
parler tant d'un point de vue
mathématique que d'un point de vue
clinique ne s'agit absolument pas
d'appliquer les algorithmes qu'on a
présenté tel quel
d'ailleurs les procédures d essais
cliniques sont horriblement plus
complexe que ce que j'ai présenté dans
cette vidéo
l'objectif de cette vidéo et de vous
présenter les grandes idées suggérées
paris mathématiques du dilemme
exploitation exploration pour mieux
guider les décisions pratiques mais même
au sujet de ses mathématiques il ya
plein de bémol à mettre en premier lieu
les modèles que j'ai présentées manque
souvent de base à nice mme en
particulier et n'inclut pas l'état
actuel des connaissances des virologues
des infectiologues et des médecins en
incluant adéquatement ses connaissances
il devrait être possible d'optimiser
encore un peu plus ses algorithmes pour
sauver encore plus de vie mais ceci
demandera une collaboration étroite
entre des mathématiciens et des experts
en santé en particulier la probabilité
de survie d'un patient donné surtout si
on connaît son état physiologique au
moment du traitement n'est pas la même
que la probabilité pour un autre patient
prend en compte ceux ci complexifie
beaucoup l'analyse et nécessité des
modèles beaucoup plus complexe
en second lieu et de façon cruciale
toute cette analyse échoue à considérer
les effets à long terme des traitements
et ça ça vient d'un problème encore plus
fondamentale qui est le fait que les
effets à long terme ne sont observables
que sur le long terme et ça a
malheureusement c'est assez incompatible
avec l'urgence de la situation actuelle
en fait la plus encore il va falloir
être bayésiens et intégrer les
connaissances biologiques pour estimer
les probabilités d'effets à long terme
grave pour différents traitements
possibles de covile 19
y compris les effets à long terme de
l'absence de traitement troisième lieu
dans cette vidéo
j'ai supposé que l'ensemble des
traitements candidats étaient connus
mais en pratique c'est bien sûr plus
compliqué que cela au fur et à mesure
que la recherche progresse de nouveaux
traitements surgissent de façon
intéressante la proche du cv semble
parfaitement adaptés à cela et peut être
appliquée informellement après
déploiement pourvu qu'on récupère bien
les données des patients ainsi traités
de façon générale intégrer efficacement
des nouvelles propositions de traitement
son but problématique intéressante à
garder en tête
un excès d'investissement sur une
solution imparfaite aujourd'hui pour est
malencontreusement freiner déçu
sion qui pourraient être découvertes
dans un futur proche bref il ya plein de
défis à relever dans l'urgence pour que
qu'ovide 19 soit traitée aussi bien que
possible mais l'urgence ne justifie
absolument pas de faire n'importe quoi
et de précipiter n'importe comment
les essais cliniques en s'appuyant sur
la rigueur des travaux de longue haleine
des statisticiens et des informaticiens
en particulier on peut sauver beaucoup
plus de vies mais pour cela il faut
prendre le temps de bien comprendre
expliquer et adapter ses travaux et
d'ailleurs sur cela j'aimerais finir
avec une situation d'un article de 2011
de civils chevret je cite depuis le
début du 21e siècle il y a eu une
croissance étonnante de l'intérêt pour
les conceptions adaptative d'essais
cliniques
malgré les avancées méthodologiques les
avantages éthique et les alternatives
data dépendante aux tests randomisé
contrôlé les essais cliniques adaptatif
bayésiens n'ont pas été très adopté en
pratique à part en début de phase 1 des
essais cliniques pour le cancer le
besoin évident de collaboration entre
statisticiens et cliniciens doit être
souligné enfin des efforts de promotion
des approches bayésienne auprès des
statisticiens et des cliniciens devrait
être fait fin de citation dans le
contexte actuel cela semble être devenu
une urgence
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
merci beaucoup à tous ceux qui ont
contribué à l'écriture notamment du
script de cette vidéo qui a été
particulièrement difficile à écrire
notamment parce que nos en temps de
crise
et du coup c'était super difficile de
faire attention à comment formuler
différentes 3
je tiens à remercier en particulier
emilie kaufmann qui est chercheuse à
l'inra à lille si je me trompe pas et
qui a donné une conférence à l'institut
henri poincaré que je m en lien à la fin
de cette vidéo sur laquelle je me suis
beaucoup appuyé et par ailleurs j'ai
découvert offert mesure après avoir créé
le premier jet du script tout le travail
qui a été fait par l' oms et l'inserm
pour mettre en place ces odeurs et titre
wireless et sa version européenne
laissée discovery quand j'ai compris
tout le dispositif qui avait été mise en
place j'ai été vraiment
absolument impressionné je sens qu'il ya
un travail absolument immense est
vraiment fantastique qui a été fait
notamment dans tout ce qui va être
gestion des données collecte des données
auprès des hôpitaux et tout ça c'est
vraiment vraiment fantastique d'avoir
mis ça en place ont si peu de temps et
du coup de permettre des essais
cliniques adaptatif qui vous rend plus
sans doute joué sur non seulement les
quatre molécules dont on a parlé mais
possiblement sur d'autres molécules et
voir modifier les doses aussi en temps
réel vraiment je suis je suis absolument
impressionné 20 ans fixation pour ce
travail merveilleux fantastique et
incroyablement utile à l'heure actuelle
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
qui n'avait pas été prévu d'insérer sur
bèze mais étant donné l'actualité je
pensais que c'était important de parler
de ce sujet il y aurait énormément plus
de choses à dire et pour cela je
recommande entendant tous toutes les
sources que j'ai mise en descriptions
que vous êtes vraiment motivé vous en
quoi le vivement à aller voir le bouquin
que j'ai cités dans cet épisode et que
je n'ai pu avoir le temps que de
survoler
mais qui a l'air très très intéressant
visiblement c'est un sujet très très
chaud comment avec l'actualité je pense
que c'est très très important de faire
preuve de beaucoup plus de prudence de
tous les côtés parce que encore une fois
les chiffres suggèrent que il faudrait
faire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
l'expérimentation pour en tirer des
conclusions sur ce qu'il faudra
administrer au plus grand nombre
et avant cela je pense que c'est très
important de s'habituer à raisonner en
termes probabiliste nom particulier sont
préparés à devoir changer d'avis le
raisonnement se d'incertitude
heureusement parisien est devenu plus
important que jamais vous avez d'autres
idées de sujets que je pourrai aborder
qui pourrait aider à sauver beaucoup
plus de vies parce que là je pense que
les biens vidéo c'est vraiment des
questions de au moins de milliers de
vies n'hésitez pas à me les proposer à
priori j'ai prévu dans deux semaines de
revenir sur les vidéos un peu plus
classique mais s'il ya bonne idée de
sujet
je suis prêt à travailler un peu plus
encore
sur mes heures perdues pour essayer de
vous offrir des informations de qualité
sur des meilleures manières peu
réfléchir surtout plein de sujets qui
souillaient avec lise du court aux
navires us et sans doute des
conséquences économiques assez grave qui
vont être conséquente de tout cela tu
faisais mais savez vous de penser le lac
et à le commenter elle partage et pensez
à vous abonner pour deux épisodes merci
aux timbers power nom et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois on est
en capacité de développer des essais des
stratégies des essais cliniques et des
stratégies thérapeutiques test des
stratégies thérapeutiques dont le but
est de pouvoir sélectionner les
meilleurs molécules pour les mettre à
disposition des patients le plus
rapidement possible l'idée c'est que
cette c'est cette recherche doit être
bien sûr pragmatique parfaitement
rationnel et qu'on doit garder la
rigueur scientifique qui nous permet de
discriminer parmi un nombre un certain
nombre de molécules les molécules qui
allie la compétence d'être à la fois
efficace et d'être bien toléré et donc
c'est tout l'objet de ce qu'on appelle
la recherche antonio en temps réel
actuellement qui est un concept un peu
nouveau et effectivement adaptatif
qu'est-ce à dire ça veut dire tout
simplement que cet essai a la capacité
de s'adapter à la situation dans la
mesure où pour l'instant nous sommes
nous partons avec cinq bras mais au fur
et à mesure des résultats que nous
allons accumuler c'est toute la force de
cet essai on à mobiliser énormément de
moyens de façon à ce que nous puissions
implémenter les résultats quasiment en
temps réel avec un recueil extrêmement
exhaustive des données au jour le jour
qui ressemble basculer et analysés qui
nous permettent de savoir précisément où
on en est précisément sur ses études
on va prouva on va s'adapter c'est à
dire quand une molécule va démontrer une
une absence d'efficacité ou trop peu
d'efficacité on pourra arrêter ce bras
et basculer potentiellement sur d'autres
molécules candidates pour faire évoluer
et accompagner le protocole vers des
molécules candidates qui seraient des
molécules d'intérêt ce que j'appelle en
aldrin de bandits bayésiens c'est un
hâle doré tout qui pour choisir le bras
suivant il va prendre déçu de la
décision en fonction de l'observation
des lois a posteriori le tout premier
article scientifique qui parlait plus ou
moins de modèles de bandits et ben c'est
un article de thomson en 1933 dans le
contexte des des essais cliniques et il
avait proposé cette algue aurait alors
l'algorithme il est très simple pour
chaque bras vous allez choix vous allez
tirer une réalisation de la loi a
posteriori et ensuite vous allez choisir
le bras qui vous a donné
l'échantillon le plus grand donc ça
c'est ce qui est écrit là où donc en
quelque sorte ce que vous faites c'est
que vous et championne est un modèle
possible selon votre a posteriori
et puis vous agissez optimalement dans
ce modèle